I think that certainly today I think
there's a lot of folks in business that
are sitting on cash this has gotten a
tremendous amount of attention three
trillion dollars sitting on corporate
balance sheets why is that I think one
of the reasons is regulation one of the
reasons is if you're the CEO of a
company and you know that in the future
the cost of employing people is going to
go up because healthcare legislation you
know that you've heard that your taxes
are likely to go up you know that the
cost of capital is likely to increase
for lots of reasons Basel three is one
of them thin reg potentially has that
impact as well the fact that there's a
wall of debt coming due also for all
those reasons you're certainly thinking
I want to put some cash aside otherwise
look I think the different rules
different regulations have an impact on
different industries certainly thin reg
a lot of the regulations are still being
thought about and have not been
implemented that'll be key for the next
several years and but that clearly will
have an impact on operations that used
to be for example at banks that will now
become independent or go into other
institutions and clearly healthcare will
have an impact there was an interesting
article in The New York Times yesterday
about the mergers that are occurring in
the healthcare space in part because the
healthcare reform was designed to
encourage more collaboration within the
healthcare industry and part of that
collaboration is occurring through
mergers so I definitely think that the
recent legislative changes will produce
significant regulatory impacts which
will then produce a business impact
certainly I think that today if your if
your goal is maximum employment the
possibility that there will be a
significant tax increase and the fact
that the cost of capital could increase
and the fact that employment that
employing workers could be more
expensive because of health care reform
all those things are likely to make a
number of companies less likely to hire
workers on the other hand others might
argue that there are societal benefits
from all three that's a fine argument to
make it's just important to understand
the realities from both perspectives
I think that the reality is because of
the legislation that's already been
passed there's likely to be a fair bit
of regulation implementing that
legislation and that'll happen going
forward you know one of the things that
often you see in government is when you
can't legislate you regulate and so I
think that that you might see in other
areas too increased regulation what I
hope though and I think you're seeing
some of it you saw in the last election
is that policy leaders will stop and
think about the fact that they really do
want jobs created in this country which
I believe they do and they'll think
about what is the impact of uncertainty
what is the impact of changing rules on
people's willingness to invest versus
leaving cash sitting on their corporate
balance sheets and that's something that
I hope then could hopefully make that
regulation some of which we know is
coming more flexible and more reasonable
and less likely to have a negative
impact on the economy